moi je peux pas être une gilet jaune en
tant que tels serge je ne peux pas aller
sur la voie publique en tant que
responsable politique dans ses ministres
mais je comprends leur colère
et j'observe à dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
femmes dans les manifestations beaucoup
de femmes c'est à dire notamment des
femmes avec des petites retraites et
pour lesquels un prélèvement sur le
pouvoir d'achat j'en entendais plusieurs
ça veut dire qu'à noël ne plus pouvoir
faire de cadeau à ses petits enfants et
je pense que quand on touche à des
choses aussi essentiels que celle ci
lorsque les femmes se mettent en
mouvement c'est que les choses vont mal
et très mal et je pense qu'il faut
écouter et prendre en considération cet
appel à l'aide
je pense qu'il y a eu plusieurs erreurs
qui ont été faites dans la décision qui
a été prise et je pense que celle qui
m'a touché le plus c'est l'utilisation
de l'écologie pour faire des impôts je
crois que l'écologie a besoin de nous
tous
la crise climatique elle est là elle est
beaucoup plus grave même qu'on ne
pouvait l'imaginer il faut agir vite
s'il faut agir fort et par conséquent il
ne faut pas faire d' écologie punitive
parce que justement on a besoin que tous
les citoyens s'engagent et si on
commence à leur dire qu'on fait des
impôts à cause de l'écologie alors rien
ne va plus
la seconde chose c'est que les citoyens
sont intelligents ils ont bien vu que ça
n'avait rien à voir avec l'écologie
cette nouvelle taxe est en tout cas je
suis cohérente avec moi même puisque
j'ai toujours refusé l'écologie punitive
et quand j'étais président de la région
donc la seule présidente écologiste
d'une région je suis également la seule
qui n'avait pas mis de taxes sur les sur
l'essence alors on pourrait donner parce
que c'est vrai que l'essence et une
énergie fossiles polluantes il faut
diminuer l'usagé mais ce qui est très
important c'est que avant de faire des
impôts il faut que le consommateur est
un libre choix
c'est ça l'écologie c'est à dire que la
fiscalité soit utilisé pour changer les
comportements
par exemple quand on est un impôt sur
une industrie qui polluent c'est pour
l'inciter à mettre en place des
procédures de de production qui ne sont
pas polluante et ça c'est je crois que
ça a été une grave erreur et que la
colère des dg les jaunes vient aussi du
fait qu'ils ont parfaitement compris
qu'on leur racontais des histoires et
qu'en fait cette taxe elle est fait pour
compenser finalement la suppression de
dollar de la taxe d'habitation